bonsoir driss ben ali merci d'être avec
nous alors nous l'a acquis assurant que
pour le moment il n'a pas du tout la
tête à la candidature de 2022 on peut le
comprendre c'est un peu prématuré mais
pourtant on a constaté qu'il avait bien
tiré à boulet rouge sur bolton avons
clairement
bonsoir bat façon il ne peut faire que
ça parce qu'il est il y pas aux affaires
était dans l'opposition c'est très
facile de se joindre au choeur mondial
contre paul son art au de tisser la
légende noire du brésil qui est le sport
favori des médias malheureusement à
l'international on pourrait revenir sur
sur ce que vient de dire lula qui
étaient aux affaires au brésil mais
pendant une douzaine d'années lui son
parti et qui ont laissé au brésil un
secteur hospitalier sanitaires
déplorables qui co qui explique en
partie le bilan du coc vide au brésil il
ya près des hôpitaux du brésil ne sont
pas nés avec bolton arrow qui est au
pouvoir depuis moins de deux ans le
régime de monsieur lula et de madame
dumas qui était dans une même partie a
bénéficié d'une conjoncture économique
merveilleuse qui aurait pu permettre de
financer les hôpitaux brésilien est
malheureusement ce peuple brésilien de
quel auxquelles monsieur roux line se
référer a été privé de ça on a préféré
faire la coupe du monde vous rappeler la
coupe du monde et les jo de rio voilà
maintenant on paie le prix on va y
revenir sur cette épidémie tobin
effectivement parce que lula a mis
l'accent dessus mais tout de même sur
ses intentions présidentielles parce que
ton on a pensé à ça forcément
hier il a quand même annoncé lula qui ne
comptait pas recourir à nouveau le pays
peut parler aux brésiliens
je cite je me sens encore assez jeune
pour lutter je veux que vous sachiez que
je n'abandonnerai jamais on rappelle
qu'il a quand même soixante quinze ans
ça ressemble quand même une future
campagne ça ah oui c'est très possible
alors bon je voudrais vous dire quand
même deux choses le contexte au brésil
ou changer et dire que le populisme de
lula a aujourd'hui parce qu'il est
populiste et ce n'est pas un mot
péjoratif il a devant lui un concurrent
de taille qui le populisme de droite de
bolt son art on est à mon humble avis a
pas place au brésil à 2 mobilisme le
peuple brésilien qui souffre hélas l'on
a raison le peuple brésilien souffre
depuis des siècles il souffre encore
plus sous le gros vide
le peuple brésilien à mon humble avis à
trouver dans ball sonar aux congés le
peuple vers les classes populaires et
les classes misérables a trouvé à mon
avis dont ball solaro le populisme je
vois mal lola maintenant venir et
reconquérir ce faible la luna est très
populaire où est populaire chez les
bourgeoisie urbaine un peu bobo à la
française parce que c'est l'idéal de che
guevara la démocratie tout ça et
deuxième chose on nous parle beaucoup de
nous la menons parlons pas de la
décision de la cour suprême brésilienne
qui l'a libéré de ses de ces contraintes
de ces condamnations
comme le fait du prince avant moyen-âge
c'est très très grave que vient de se
passer au brésil
si on en a effectivement parlé hier
quand c'est tombé mais apparemment vous
avez envie d'en parler très bien la cour
suprême brésilienne enfin ça veut dire
aussi puisqu'on parle de ça que lula n'a
pas du tout été innocenté qu'il devra
peut-être certainement affronter un
autre tribunal
et ça sera peut-être une autre paire de
manches peut-être quand même condamné un
on n'en sait rien il ya une prescription
non j'ai pas le chiffre en tête un jeu
combien d'années à partir desquels les
crimes sont pardonnés ya prescription
donc ils vont jouer ça certainement ce
que lula n'est pas n'est pas le
brésilien de batasuna ab parmi les
meilleurs avocats du brésil
et deuxième chose le brésil aujourd'hui
leur prix parce que vous avez quelqu'un
qui a été jugé par 15 juin
brésil qu'un juge trois instances il a
déposé sans recours tous rejetés il a
fait de la prison et vous avez un juge
dans la cour suprême qui comme ça se
réveille le matin il dit eh bien on
n'aurait pas dû juger lula à curitiba
dans un tribunal de province qu'on
aurait dû juger à brasilia et donc vous
avez la juge qui est un droit
plusieurs années plus tard de dire que
tout le monde s'est trompé bien vous
imaginez le signal qui on voyait la
communauté internationale aux
investisseurs donc je ne sais pas si
lula sera à mon humble avis il ne sera
pas embêtés d'ici 2022 d'un point de vue
juridique
je pense pas qu'il soit encore devant
les tribunaux d'ici 2022 je pense qu'il
va le chemin qui est libre alors tout
cas il ya un sondage qui a été rendu
public aujourd'hui par l'institut real
time data passionnel brasil il donne de
bonnes sonar ou en tête des intentions
de vote en résidence et a tout de suite
mais enfin c'est intéressant pour le
premier tour avec 43 % ont talonné par
lula 39% qu'est-ce que samedi ce sondage
justement selon vous il faudrait
regarder les l'art et les régions
effectivement parce qu'il ya un cas le
vote ball sont arrêtés un vote du sud
est et du centre ouest ont dans les
régions disons entre guillemets un même
s'il faut faire plusieurs lieux mais les
plus riches du brésil en sort paulo rio
et la région de centre ouest daver
brasilia et la gauche avait pris le
nordeste les gens les plus pauvres
j'ai l'impression que ball son art au
s'implante fortement lord est à creusot
grâce aux crocs vite parce qu'il a
distribué beaucoup d'argent de l'aide
sociale il faudrait voir dans ses
intentions de vote
roux lula aurait encore ces 39%
de toute façon le brésil est largement
fracturé un c il a un côté nord
américain il ya les antilles les pro
bowl somaro et les gens ne se parlent
plus c'est dramatique jeu
jamais vu ça au brésil qui est un pays
qu'on sensuelle où la politique est
moins importante que le foot
et bien pourtant les gens ne se parlent
plus les familles sont divisées
c'est c'est comme ça c'est la
polarisation merci de risque gagner
d'abord été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour parler de la situation
brésil est particulièrement de lula
merci à vous